Transcriber: Aleyna Erbayrakci
Gözden geçirme: Başak Gökdaş
Herkese merhaba.
Ben bugün size kendi
hikâyemi değil,
babası İSKİ’de memur annesi ev hanımı olan
bir kızın hikâyesini anlatacağım.
Bu kız lise eğitiminden sonra üniversiteye
babası tarafından
gönderilmemiş ve hayallerine
balta vurulan bir kız.
Bu kız okumak için, yaşamak için,
çalışmak için
delicesine istek duyan bir kız.
Bu kız benim annem.
Annem lise eğitiminden sonra
altı kardeşler ve
altı kardeşlerin en büyüğü annem.
O yüzden kaderi baştan çizilmiş.
Arkadaşlarına bakacak, ay arkadaşlarına
bakacak diyorum, kardeşlerine bakacak,
arkadaşlarıyla vakit geçirmeyecek,
annesine ev işlerinde yardım edecek.
Bunların hepsi önceden belli.
O yüzden üniversiteye gönderilmiyor.
Aslında İstanbul Üniversitesi’nde
Öğretmenlik bölümünü kazanıyor ama
büyük babam tarafından okula
gönderilmesine izin verilmiyor.
Tabi bunlardan sonra annem pes ediyor ve
daha sonra bir arkadaşının vasıtasıyla
Ziraat Bankası’nın sınavlarına giriyor ve
Ziraat Bankası’nın sınavını kazanarak
bankada çalışmaya başlıyor.
Tabii büyük babamın haberi yok durumdan.
Anneannemle işbirliği yapıyorlar.
Sonra git gel büyük babam İSKİ
de çalıştığı için Kadıköy’de
evden erken çıkıyor.
Annemde o gittikten sonra var olan 2 çift
kıyafeti ile işe gitmeye başlıyor.
Sonra gel zaman git zaman annemin
çalıştığı anlaşılıyor
ve evde büyük bir yaygara kopuyor.
Daha sonra büyük babam diyor ki: “Bir
şartla çalışmana izin vereceğim.
O da şu.
Maaş dekontu ile birlikte bütün
maaşını bana getireceksin.”
Annem de tabii ki kabul ediyor.
Ne yapacak ki?
Yapacak bir şey yok.
İlk maaşıyla birlikte sonrakileri de
büyük babama veriyor
ve çalışmaya o şekilde devam ediyor.
Bugün annem bir Ziraat Bankası’ndan
yönetmen olarak emekli olmuş bir memur
ve ben kendi gücünü eline almak için
savaş veren bir kadının kızıyım.
Ama herkes benim kadar şanslı değil.
Çünkü şu anda hâlâ hayatın kıyısında
duran çocuklar var.
Sudaki yansımalarını bile
görmüş değiller henüz.
Ve o çocuklara hep önlerine bakmaları
söylenmiş; söyleneni yapmaları,
durmadan dinlemeleri söylenmiş; hiçbir
şey yorumlamamaları söylenmiş.
Sürekli böyle çocuklar bastırılmış
duygularla büyütülmüşler.
Ve her yıl bu ülkede, bu coğrafyada,
dünyamızda,
çocukluğu elinden alınan kız çocuklarının
sayısı gün geçtikçe artıyor maalesef.
Ve biz
onlara destek olup yardım etmek
durumundayız ve bunun farkına varmalıyız.
Çünkü kendisini tanımayan, susturulan,
hayatı bilmeyen bir çocuk
gelişi güzel savrulur.
Yaşamaya devam edemez.
Dolayısıyla ben bugün sizinle hikayesi,
hayatı orada yarım kalmış çocuklardan
bahsetmek istiyorum.
Türkiye’de normalde temel eğitim
Cumhuriyet döneminde yasalarla kurulmuş
biliyorsunuz ve şu anda da ilköğretim
Türkiye’de zorunlu
ve parasız olarak devam ediyor normalde.
Ama 2003 UNICEF verilerine baktığımızda
o zaman yedi buçuk milyon insan okuma
yazma bilmiyordu
ve maalesef bu yedi buçuk milyon insanın
altı milyonu kadındı.
Neden kadınları okula göndermiyoruz?
Neden biz de iyi bir müdür, biz
de iyi bir resim çizen,
biz de iyi bir sanatçı olamıyoruz.
Neden korkuyorsunuz
bizim okumamızdan bu kadar?
Biz de her şeyi en az erkekler
kadar iyi yapabiliriz.
Biz de her zaman kız çocukları da
her zaman okumayı
en az erkekler kadar hak ediyor.
Ve 2003 yılından sonra,
yaklaşık 18 yıl sonra bugüne geldiğimizde
UNICEF’in verileri tekrarlanıyor.
Tabii aralarda tekrarlamaya devam ediyor
ve şu andaki verilere göre Türkiye’de 600
bin kız çocuğu okula, ilköğretim çağında
olmasına rağmen okula gönderilmiyor.
Ve okumak için her şeyi feda edebilecek
iken bu çocuklar okula gönderilmiyorlar.
Peki neden okula göndermiyorlar
bu çocukları?
Gelenekler var bunun içinde, dini inançlar
var, maddi yetersizlikler var
veya okula yazılıyorlar,
devam edemiyorlar,
tamamlayamıyorlar bir şekile,
ev içindeki sorumlulukları var
az önce annemden bahsettiğim gibi,
bir de tabii ki hepinizin bildiği gibi
çocuk evlilikleri var.
Evlendiriliyorlar.
Son 25 yılın en büyük, yani kız çocukların
evliliğinde en büyük artışı görüldü
hatta son 18 yılda 542 bin 821
tane kız çocuğu evlendirildi.
Ve bu sayının 20 bin tanesi de
maalesef ki
bu çocukların 15 yaşın altında
bu kız çocukları.
Dolayısıyla şimdi burada durup
gördüğünüz her kız çocuğuna
yaşamı, aynası elinden alınmış biri gibi
bakmanızı istiyorum.
Ve kendini hiç görmemiş birine
kendini nasıl anlatırsınız?
Hayatı bir noktada dondurulmuş o donuk
yüze nasıl can verirsiniz?
Termodinamiğin ikinci yasasına göre
evrendeki düzensizlik
yani entropi sürekli artıyor.
Yani bir şeyin dağınık ve düzensiz olma
ihtimali
düzenli olma ihtimaline göre daha fazla.
Ben de diyorum ki gelin bu olasılıkları
değiştirelim.
O kız çocuklarına  bir şans daha verelim.
Onları o yaşamın kıyısından alalım.
Yaşamın kaydırağına bindirelim,
istedikleri yere özgürce,
doya doya kürek çeksinler diyorum.
Haykırsınlar özgürce istediklerini,
istediği, istediğini söylesinler.
Eğer biz bunları yapabilirsek işte o
zaman bu dünyayı değiştirebiliriz.
Ben bugün annemin o susturulduğu ve hayata
tamam dediği ve buna zorlandığı noktadan,
annemin öğretmen kızı olarak
hayata devam diyorum
ve hepinizin
hayata devam demenizi istiyorum.
Beni dinlediğiniz için
çok teşekkür ederim.
Sağ olun.